foreign
and I've been repairing and restoring
typewriters for nearly a decade and I'm
going to show you how to restore a 90
year old Royal typewriter this
particular machine was purchased new in
India by a family member of my client to
him it is a family or living these
serial number places it in the second
half of 1930 in its current condition it
is not a functioning machine
the first pieces to come off of the
typewriter the Platinum knobs as well as
the plant which is to be replaced
and then I'll remove the body shells
I'll also remove the paper table the
bail roller assembly paper tray and the
feed rollers
usually Carriage disassembly stops there
but on cases of really rough machines
such as this one the internal type bars
and the actuator rods are all removed
from the machine and set aside from
Individual cleaning
[Music]
the first step is to cast with an air
compressor to dislodge large sections of
dirt and debris
[Music]
here I'm using a wire brush attachment
higher drill to get into hard to reach
places
[Music]
after the bulk of the rust is removed
everything gets to pass with mineral
spirits with a soft Crystal thrust
after the cleaning is finished all of
the bare metal surfaces get wiped with
the red to remove any of the residue
thank you
the keyboard on this machine was also
intensely discolored
keyring is carefully removed from the
key top I'm using a special key ring
remover plier from the early 1900s
anytime that you're working with a glass
keyboard you run the risk of breaking
Keys due to the age of the tools and the
hardened rubber about half of this Glass
Circle in the keyboard ended up
shattering
once all of the keys are disable the
paper Legends are removed
foreign
circles also get cleaned here I'm using
a razor blade to scrape off all of the
accumulated corrosion that is stuck to
the surface of the glass then they are
each individually hand polished with a
fine grade Polishing Compound
if new glass Rings need to be fabricated
they are cut by hands from around a 16
inch thick piece of glass
this is a common glass standard
thickness or feature frames
foreign
any Springs that are missing on the
typewriter get replaced over time they
can sometimes stretch or can become
damaged if a machine Falls
Minnesota replaced
and I also create new feed welders using
old rubber hosing or sometimes layers of
heat shrink
now I install the paper table this is
the piece of metal that holds both the
feed rollers in place and guides the
paper around the platen
the most difficult part about assembling
Royal Typewriters are the ball bearings
here I'm using his drinking straw to
insert them into the proper placement
along the carriage rail
now the tricky part is the ribbon
vibrator or the ribbon lifting Fork here
you can see me attaching it with a small
counter pin
the key Legends also need to be
carefully placed so that they are
aligned vertically
these king ring needs to be seated
properly with the key rate installation
tool and then once each key top on the
machine is completely set the bottom
plate of the keyring installation tool
gets rotated to a flat portion of the
plate which is used to seat down all of
the tabs on the bottom of the key ring
firmly against the bottom of the key
cover
[Music]
the second and last step is to
reassemble everything completely
all typewriters are individually
adjusted so that the parts work well
together
so when you take certain parts from one
machine to fill into another machine
that is missing those parts you will
need to adjust those parts to work with
each other
once everything is carefully together I
install the brand new Rubber and the
feet as well as the new ribbon
[Music]
foreign
once the ribbon is in the machine the
type testing begins
the primary things that I'm looking for
are evenness of the letters alignment
between the capital and lowercase margin
consistency and line scale height
the escapement must also be adjusted so
that it is moving the proper distance
both up and down to prevent skipping or
missed spaces
then I move on to adjusting the height
of the ribbon to ensure that the entire
letter is being printed
the case is usually a secondary thing to
the typewriter that I generally don't
spend a lot of time with but this
particular one needed a little bit of
care unfortunately the based on the case
where it mounts to the machine had two
strips of water in place of the four
over feet that are supposed to be there
and there's no way to actually Mount the
machine to it so here I'm removing these
wood rails and then it's Drilling and
conscious sinking holes for the screws
and the feet that will Mount the machine
to the base
the final step is to cut a strip of
leather and to punch holes to stitch the
new handle onto the case
this was probably one of the worst rails
that I have seen cosmetically that being
said theoretically there is no amount of
damage that is physically irrepairable
however that does come a point when the
cost of repair far exceeds the value of
the machine both monetarily and
sentimentally
and in essence that is how I restore
antique typewriters any machine from the
mid-1800s to as late as 2020 follows
pretty much the same exact procedures
[Music]